just wondering how can i gain on-demand  hands-on cloud experience with google  cloud and demonstrate my skills  have you heard about google cloud skill  badges  please tell me more  well skill badges are shareable  credentials that recognize your ability  to solve real-world problems with cloud  knowledge  so  how does it work exactly  pick your quest  complete the challenge lab at the end of  the quest to prove your skill  earn a google cloud digital skill badge  share your skill badge on your social  profiles or resume  thank you for letting me know about  skill badges where do i begin  check out cloud.google.com  training  badges and good luck